welcome to this video playing tourist us
to estas from Italy let's see okay he
does not want the the Senor Philidor d5
is an interesting recommendation I I
once saw against that leading to really
is really strange play but interesting
play okay thank you
yeah this was a bit bit dull this this
continuation check wow this is really
done he'll get c3
see three years a bit surprising not
yeah not a terrible move but still it
surprised that he didn't play just
castles long okay the question is hmm
yeah I really don't need to fear the
doubling of the sea pony it's it's two
bishops after all 93 is this idea camera
let's let's go here
ya can do H 5 H 5 I want not to not sure
that it's helping much
yeah I said I think what I need to be
aware of is that I'm probably not better
I mean it's probably about equal he
plated is quite modest modest term a
fashion but it's not necessarily bad my
bond structure is not not great
Joe you've probably played g3 and now
the big question is should I kill the
game with Bishop takes d4 can I do
something something active my pawn
structure really is bad
yeah okay it's a not very ambitious of
course
with opposite colored bishops this is
some basically dead this position
yeah white is the slightly better
structure but no way is going to to do
anything with it
yeah probably this first yeah I think
many many possible moves hmm you know I
can go see five now get rid of one of
the weaknesses
I cannot sorry do you want the oneness
of course covered yeah okay well just a
normal move then okay
gee fire fear maybe maybe can go 45
I can like play rook a 6-row Kade going
from play on the FL I am the the issue
could be an exchange second at the right
moment and combined with this Bishop
anthem and the H pawn an h4 h5 and so on
I'm hoping to have enough play on the
8th I cannot spend much more time okay
so he wants to enhance the trade
and yeah I played this I played this
really badly far to a superficial hmm
not sure if this is still a draw it
probably is but I'm not sure okay yeah
okay that this point is not important
and I think it's a draw already and the
king here controls the important squares
and he cannot cannot advance while my
bishop is staying on this diagonal yeah
that's it wrong the position is a draw
we can he can try to play on time of
course okay this I forgot about but
still time warning hmm you can do all
the way takes checks
it's super fun it's
what it's on time yeah that's a desert
loss I mean I really I really felt a bit
of sleep in this game it's very very
difficult to lose this position but I
managed for example I just need to play
h5 at some point and and then it's just
completely dead preventing this g4 ideas
I just thought okay I can't play
anything and I cannot probably at least
I can admit and it I need to switch at
the right moment to - to saving to
saving mode and that's it's so
completely dead I mean this is even good
for black but I didn't have this idea at
all this wins an important attacking
tempo yeah and this this is now highly
critical really critical maybe and I'm
not the company you cannot trust here
really this is it's not it's not
calculating fine of check this it looks
it looks very three thought it is a draw
around here but maybe this deflection
with the b-pawn is really decisive so
that's possible of course
and he will go all the way to just have
nights it's cannot prevent that
okay yeah then see five versus just just
just just stupid I was a bit concerned
that that he tried this this kind of
idea
then without sea-fight really
yeah maybe the compound supply c5 and
lose it's not calculating deep enough at
least I think it loses yeah I must have
what this move probably just just stay
put if he tries to go down I need to
block it like this we can always go he
janitor to pushing back hard to tell
hard to say that this is a draw
yeah probably it should be but hmm
silly mates remains tricky yeah yeah I
just I was far too far too relaxed him
and I didn't spot any chances I only
only now recognized that this rook rook
a one octave and okay one is a problem
and this this for example is not so
difficult to see I mean my double pawn
is useless anyway and here he has got
some real problems needs to play move
like that in and here black is really
active I don't have any problems here at
all yeah I fail to spot that thanks for
watching